[Music]
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists
[Applause]
is there a luxury item that you'd
purchase right now if you had unlimited
money if so what is it on today's
podcast episode we're going to talk
about so-called luxury items desiring
them purchasing them clinging to them
understanding them and ultimately
letting go of them then this thursday on
the minimalist private podcast ryan and
i are going to talk about the emotional
and psychological pain that arises when
we constantly need more stuff we're also
going to talk about the luxury items
that both of us would purchase
immediately if we had unlimited money
you can check that out at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck our first question
today is from patty
how do you define luxury item is a 200
leather purse considered a luxury when
it will outlast any cheap plastic purse
well patty i think this is such an
interesting question to start the
episode off with now ryan when you hear
the word luxury it can conjure up all
kinds of images now i think when people
talk about luxury they're often talking
about two different things it's either
really high in something high-end
high-quality sometimes we i don't think
it's necessarily high quality or it
means excessive if you buy a really
expensive wrist watch it may be high-end
and handmade and it may work really well
but if it's a hundred thousand dollar
watch that may be a bit excessive
especially for your average person i
know it'd be excessive for me yeah of
course man yeah luxury to me
man um
it can mean all sorts of different
things uh driving in my car is a luxury
i would consider that um living in a
democracy i would consider that a luxury
uh but of course that's because i'm
comparing my situation to
you know third world country situations
um but here in america maybe if you're
comparing it to other americans maybe
it's not a luxury does does that factor
in all like who we're comparing i think
that's that's an important point there
is maybe much of what we're talking
about when we talk about luxury is
steeped in comparison
and so something is luxurious relative
to the average population perhaps right
and so i think sometimes something can
be high-end without it being luxurious
we just bought some new microphones
we're not using them yet because we
still need to test them out by the way
we got peter duffy here he mixed our
first documentary minimalism and he's
helping us with some more audio stuff
and we bought these new microphones
they're very high-end
they're neumann's
they're like the broadcast standard of
microphones and they're i wouldn't call
them a luxury necessarily though because
the there isn't an alternative that is
in that same sort of
area that is like oh but yeah it
accomplishes the same exact thing this
microphone does but for half the price
and it's not diamond studded or all
these other things we think about when
we think about luxurious so something
can be high in without it being a luxury
good but i also think that we've
somewhat rendered this word meaningless
with marketing yeah you drive past
certain apartment complexes and it says
luxury apartment and it looks all run
down you're like are you sure this is a
what do you mean by luxury yeah i don't
even know what that means anymore right
i i in fact last night i was walking up
on sunset boulevard and i saw this um
billboard it was jay-z and beyonce and
it was an ad for tiffany and co you know
the jewelry company
and it said about love on it that's all
i said tiffany and co about love so
they're trying to sell love commodify
love
and it looked very luxurious it looked
high-end they had this
basquiat painting in this photograph of
jay-z and beyonce and they're trying to
sell you what i would consider to be
faux luxury
tiffany and co these are a bunch of
really overpriced pieces of jewelry that
we buy why why do we buy a lot of these
these things
yeah to show our love for our partner to
show them that we really care yes um
yeah it's interesting uh but okay so but
you so you're saying that the tiffany
and co is not a luxury i mean it can be
pre like i said this word has been
rendered meaningless and hopefully we
can we can identify what luxurious means
to the average person but to me i don't
see
luxury in that i see a lot of stress
and anxiety and comparison as you said
right
and so
i guess it kind of means what we mean by
luxury yeah it sounds like luxury can be
really it comes down to perspective
absolutely it is perspectival and so one
person's luxury
may be accessed to someone else but we
do have some definitions here so i have
marion webster's dictionary definition
here and then i've got something from
wikipedia as well so can you tell me
about the essential meaning of luxury
ryan a condition or situation of great
comfort
ease
and wealth comfort ease and wealth
so
maybe by that definition tiffany and co
would not be
luxurious because is it i mean how is it
comfortable right well i mean it's
adding you have to have a pretty
comfortable life if you can quote invest
waste your money on tiffany and co right
yeah and and so maybe there's a comfort
aspect there in fact i think the tiffany
company actually falls under this
definition of
luxury but what else do we mean when we
say luxury i think sometimes we confuse
luxury with
elegance
right this studio is elegant it's well
put together it's artistic thanks to
beulah who painted the artwork and did
the interior design of the studio it's
simple
but that's actually why it's elegant we
get down to the bones of the thing the
bones are the beauty and so i wouldn't
call this studio luxurious someone else
might and i wouldn't correct them for it
but to me it seems more elegant than it
does a a particular luxury i like these
other two definitions here in the
merriam-webster dictionary so you got
something that is expensive and not
necessary
so like going back to our microphones
they're expensive but they are necessary
yes so i could see where that would not
be luxury uh according to the second
definition something that is helpful or
welcome and that is not usually or
always available so i think that's why i
look at like driving my car
as a luxury because
it's convenient it's not always
available to everyone that's right yeah
so yeah interesting yeah and so i think
the other thing that we often do is we
conflate
luxury with trendy or
expensive you know i think of like down
on fairfax where they have all these
stores with really expensive sneakers or
the supreme store and you buy a 200
limited edition t-shirt that's not
luxury necessarily it's trendy
and and it's expensive
but it's not even necessarily high
quality that's another thing we do we
conflate high quality with luxury or we
say something is luxury because it's
high quality i have a pocket knife at
home that's handmade and it's very high
quality i don't know that i would call
it a luxury item necessarily if you saw
it you i i don't know that anyone would
necessarily call it but it is like a
piece of art in a way and even this art
here this art is high quality
i don't know that i would call it
a luxury item although by some of these
definitions you just read ryan is it
necessary well no almost everything we
own isn't truly necessary that's why we
have the no junk rule right everything
you own can fit in one of three piles
it's either
essential it's non-essential but
value-adding or it's junk and
quite often
the luxury items so-called luxury items
are actually just junk i was walking
down melrose avenue last night and i see
some of these stores they're really
high-end stores and they sell luxury
goods i was doing this just to prepare
for this episode
and i realized like some of these places
make high-quality goods i walked past
lululemon which is on melrose
i don't know that i would call those
luxury goods necessarily but they
probably are more high-end than
something you would buy off of amazon or
something right yeah but then right next
door is a
clothing store called vince and it's
really high-end and probably
high-quality goods there as well
but
those probably are considered luxury
goods so i think quite often it's just
in the mind the perception of
the perceiver right yeah no i totally
agree well let's go let's go back to
patty's question here a 200 leather
purse i love how this is in a 200 gucci
bag or 200 like there's no brand name
here right it's about the quality well
because
wouldn't that be like a six thousand
dollar gucci bear whatever those are
right exactly yeah but quality that's
important yeah so so you know uh patty
first off
it's up to you whether or not you
consider that a luxury good josh are not
gonna sit here and say that is or isn't
um but i will give you permission to
call it a non-luxury good if it's truly
the only thing that you can purchase
that's going to do the job that you
wanted to do the best again it's kind of
going back to those microphones it's
like those microphones we need to have
nice microphones for this podcast right
uh we i think we are fortunate to be
able to afford microphones like that
thanks to our patrons yes um but is it a
luxury yeah i i personally i would not
consider the microphones a luxury so
patty it's up to you and maybe sometimes
what luxury means is hey i'm trying to
impress other people and that's why it's
a luxury good
and so we're not trying to impress
anyone with look at the neumann
microphone that i have aren't you
impressed i don't know who that that
would impress like a select handful of
broadcasters at radio stations across
the united states but it's not
necessarily going to make any difference
to the average person although it will
make an aesthetic an audio aesthetic
difference that will improve our overall
sound on the podcast that's why we did
it but are they absolutely essential no
these mics have worked just fine for us
for many years and even the mics we had
before these which were cheaper than
these they worked fine for a while and
so patty yes you have
a more expensive purse perhaps or maybe
you're considering a more expensive
purse but just because something is 200
doesn't mean it's going to be higher
quality
than the purse that is one-fourth that
cost as well so i wouldn't confuse
expensive with
luxury
we have a question here from cassidy in
minneapolis minnesota my fiance and i
will be registering for a wedding soon
and we're wondering if you had any
advice for us we've recently gotten rid
of a lot of our stuff and don't want to
accumulate it all back
other than just not registering for a
lot how would you recommend that we do
this so cassidy we have a podcast
episode about minimalist weddings you
can go back and listen to that what
number was it
249 jordan no more is telling me
and um so you can go back we we had a
guest expert on the podcast jessica to
talk about that and um so
there's one place to start but beyond
that the reason i thought this was an
appropriate question for this episode is
quite often we get a bunch of
unnecessary stuff dude i think about
yeah when i got married at 19 years old
we signed up for our wedding registry
95 of it was luxury uh-huh it was like
it was like you're going through because
you know uh back then it wasn't so we
like you couldn't go online and shop as
easily as you can now so we had to go to
the man i'm so old
we had to go to the actual store
and like you have a list that you're
checking stuff or you're writing stuff
down that's right and uh
a lot of the things that went on that
list
went on there simply because we were
like well we can ask for it
you know and if someone wants to get it
for us great so we got you know
fine china and
a waffle maker and
whatever else man whatever whatever you
know luxurious thing luxurious thing
that we definitely didn't need
so like when it comes to
um cassidy's question here
you know
personally now this is me as one of the
minimalists i would not have a registry
um i mean that's how i would solve that
problem because i know what what's gonna
happen is like i'm going to start
signing up
for things that you know me and my
partner would want
um but they are it's just gonna be a lot
of non-essential and probably a lot of
junk on there as well yeah i think in
fact what you're describing here is many
of the things you have were just junk
items that kind of felt like oh it'd be
kind of cool to have the the fine china
or whatever yeah meek mill just came out
with a new album it's called expensive
pain
that was original i was going to call
this episode because
what a great title about luxury items
when you think about all the pain that's
striving for this excess
for this over abundance for this
these non-necessities and for this junk
yeah it's a lot of expensive pain we we
neurose
over if i just had that then i'll be
more complete i'll be happier i'll feel
more content other people will like me
more
and you mentioned the fine china
now our friend rob bell he talks about
how they always use the fine china every
night yes and so at that point is it a
luxury item yeah probably but quite
often here's what people do they buy the
fine china they stick it in a cabinet as
like a sort of display thing
but they never use it for its intended
purpose right what if you actually use
those
quote unquote luxury goods then maybe
they're not junk if you're actually
getting value from them every single day
or every week or you know whatever rule
you want to put in place there
then it's not excess it's not excessive
you're actually enjoying the things that
you own yeah i think it's interesting
how cassidy just talked about how they
have just gotten rid of a bunch of stuff
uh-huh and so they don't want to bring
more stuff into their life now cassidy i
just want to be clear if you sign up for
a registry great like that's there's
nothing wrong with doing that but just
know that you are opening up yourself
and your partner to
recluttering your home
but again if you want to do that that's
okay we're not here to judge right um if
is there a minimalist approach to a
registry
i don't i mean i don't know i mean i
guess if let's say mariah and i were
getting married we had to sign up for a
registry uh-huh
i think it would be
we would just check things that like we
currently didn't have
um but i would but i certainly wouldn't
check any boxes that
uh felt like oh it would be nice to have
this or
maybe you know we'll just check this
really expensive item because maybe
someone will go out of their way to get
us this expensive item right but um but
the thing is is like mariah and i have
everything we need right now that's
right so i don't can't even think of a
box i would check maybe i would i would
posit the idea uh propose the idea of an
alternative registry so if bex and i
were gonna have a wedding
and
people felt like oh i want to be able to
contribute to this matrimony here
great then an alternative registry
registry would be here are the charities
yeah that i would love for you to donate
in our name so i feel good about myself
and it you know helps my ego out that
now i'm i'm also contributing to charity
right yeah but it also makes you feel
good because you're not buying me
another waffle iron i know on that
episode 249 i talked about how um
i got three bread makers
during my wedding i don't even eat bread
i think someone was telling you that
they wanted you to be a baker
[Laughter]
they weren't even like they were the
yeah anyway they were like these bread
makers i used one of them once or we
used one of them once i didn't actually
use it
and then we nev we stored them forever
so it just took up space
they were unnecessary they were in the
way but an alternative wedding registry
could be what adds value to my life now
experiences charitable giving that's
what i would prefer you spend your money
on so maybe i make a list of here are
the experiences
here's how much cash we could use to pay
for this wedding maybe that's even part
of it or you can donate to here are our
five favorite charities you can donate
in our name i totally saw a friend of
mine at his wedding him and his wife
basically
uh had like a gofundme or uh
you know some kind of crowdsourced
account
and they were like hey here's what we
want to do we want to go on this
honeymoon
uh here's the wedding here you know so
they listed out like certain experiences
uh and they were like you know here's
how much it costs feel free to donate
whatever you want um and like to me that
was that was genius right which what's
funny though because like 20 years ago i
feel like people would have looked at
that like i can't believe they're asking
for money
but like now in like the crowdsourcing
world we live in i mean you've got
people
putting up you know a gofundme because
they want uh
they want a manicure
yeah yeah it's absurd but if you are
showing people what the money's for it's
it's as though you're not asking them
for money you're asking them for a
vacation it's a crowd-sourced vacation
or it's a crowd source donating to
charity or it's crowdsourced something
that's going to improve our household
right these are things that you'll
actually get value from isn't that so
much better than just saying well here's
a list of trinkets that might be kind of
nice to have but if i'm honest i'm
probably not going to use them yeah
yeah careful you don't want to
re-clutter your home cassidy cassidy
we're going to send you a couple tickets
to our minneapolis event we're on tour
we're actually in the middle of a tour
right now it's called the love people
use things tour we've already been the
nine cities you can find all nine of
those events over on patreon if you
didn't get a chance to attend or if you
want to come to these other 11 cities
we're going to be in the midwest we'll
be on the east coast new york i think
it's sold out but boston
washington dc toronto columbus ohio
chicago minneapolis vancouver seattle
san francisco and of course here in los
angeles the minimalists.com tour to find
the city closest to you i had a dream
last night that i forgot my speech what
does it mean
what does it mean
i have that i have that dream all the
time i'm on stage and i can't remember a
word of of the the talk that i'm giving
in the beginning
it's funny he says i've had this dream
once
where you forgot yours
well it's actually happened before maybe
that's a piece of it too oh yeah but
well not yeah but here's the thing i the
dream i have was like i've heard the
speech so many times that i just got up
and he gave it for me i tried to give it
but like it's so much harder because i'm
not i don't i don't have it down right
yeah so if you want to see ryan stumble
through a speed no just kidding
ryan's got an amazing talk down we talk
about minimalism we do a live version of
the podcast i read from our new book
which is called love people use things
because the opposite never works and we
do a live version of the podcast where
we answer a bunch of your questions the
minimalists.com tour for a city near you
or you can find all 20 live events as we
publish them over at patreon.com
the minimalist ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to 937-202-4654
yes indeed now during the lightning
round this is where ryan and i do our
best to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now
thanks to jessica lynn williams you can
find all of our minimal maxims in one
place minimalmaxims.com
ryan we got a question from zane
what's the point of pursuing luxury
instead of just living within your means
isn't that the same as just pursuing an
outcome wouldn't it be simpler to
purchase only what you need
okay so i think we're talking about
several different things when
it's the whole conversation we had when
we answered patty's question about the
definition of luxury so i want to dive a
little bit deeper with this ryan this is
from wikipedia which i know is always
factual especially our wikipedia page
you literally edited it before you
printed it didn't you yeah on the luxury
goods i actually just wrote the page
and then printed it out here's what it
says about luxury goods in economics a
luxury good or quote upmarket good is a
good for which demand increases more
than proportionally as income rises so
that expenditures on the good become a
greater proportion of overall spending
that's simple right i have no idea what
you just said we'll get into it right
and so uh luxury goods are in contrast
to necessity goods where demand
increases proportionately
less than income luxury goods are often
used synonymously with superior goods
the word luxury originated from the
latin root
luxuria which means
exuberance
access
or abundance
now those are different things because
i know you very well ryan and you
approach life with an abundance mindset
now but not necessarily with an
excessive mindset i need to get this i
need to get this i need to get this
right
also you're very exuberant right
and so
i wouldn't confuse all of these things
but it's interesting a luxury
ryan it's a real luxury to have you here
today thanks man likewise so the
definition that they have on wikipedia
says this a luxury good can be
identified by comparing the demand for
the good at one point in time against
the demand for the good at a different
point in time
with a different income level
when income increases demand for luxury
goods increases even more than income
does basically what are they saying here
as soon as you cover your necessities
you start looking for
external ways to meet your pleasure
how how can i be pleased
by getting more stuff yeah that's why
you have um
no matter what
where someone falls on the socioeconomic
scale they can have a 60-inch tv in
their house at this point right yeah
right whereas before that was so far out
of reach it was impossible 100 years ago
right
it was virtually impossible 50 years ago
and even 20 years ago it was so priced
that
highly that there was you know top one
percent sort of thing yeah and now
virtually anyone can have it so
something that was a luxury good because
it becomes ubiquitously available ceases
to be a luxury good that goes back to
what you said isn't this about
perception yeah it's the same freaking
thing it is and so
when i'm talking about the market
characteristics here of
a luxury good here's what wikipedia has
to say luxury goods have high income
elasticity of demand
so this is also um
when you think about
well drugs for example that there's this
term inelasticity of demand so the
demand continues even if you
even if the market over floods with
supply or whatever it's not the regular
supply demand curve right gotcha here's
what it says as people become wealthier
they will buy proportionately more
luxury goods obviously that's on average
there's you know there's footage of jeff
bezos driving a a honda accord when he
was worth nine billion dollars and so
there are obvious exceptions to this
yeah yeah elon musk famously recently
got rid of like all his houses and
moved to a tiny apartment it's pretty
inspiring like we've had uh i don't know
if i should
well we've had we have a friend who
multi multi multi multi-millionaire
and they drive like a 2004 oldsmobile
that's paid off and you would never
think that they were worth so much money
right yeah anyway now the opposite is
also true right when we see some of
these lamborghinis flying down la siena
boulevard or something those people
don't a often don't own it it's leased
for the day or the week or whatever
or it's someone living so far beyond
their means not always but quite often
you can't afford the car and so you go
into debt to get this quote-unquote
luxury good which brings us back to
zane's question here what's the point of
pursuing luxury instead of just living
within your means
amen
ryan during your talk while we're on
tour you one thing you talk about
minimalism is hey if minimalism is too
radical for you you can just call it
living within your means ism yeah
now
that's what we
that's what we do right now is we live
within our means on the maximal episode
i do want to talk to you about if we had
unlimited money is there a luxury good
or a handful of luxury goods that you
might splurge on let's just say
tiffany's and company
[Laughter]
but zayn i have something pithy for you
here and then we can unpack it the thing
you want is never the thing
you want we always want the the feeling
that that thing is going to bring to us
so if you want a
lamborghini it's not that you actually
want the lamborghini you think it's
going to make you feel a particular way
it's going to impress the people you
want to impress it's going to attract
the people you want to attract it's
going to make you feel significant in
front of the people to whom you want to
be significant yeah you know i think
there are certainly
car enthusiasts out there yeah that
would buy a lamborghini because of the
love that they have for you know that
art
um
but
i would i would i would say that's
probably a small percentage and it just
is interesting to me how
yeah they want the status they want the
superiority yes yeah um
yeah so anytime you're buying something
expensive ask yourself like why
are you getting that is it for the
superiority is it for the status is it
so you can show off to your friends
because if you do that well then
that's a never-ending chase right who am
i buying this for
and if it is the chase what are you
doing you're either running toward more
significance more status more impressive
self it's fueling the ego or you're
running away from something right oh my
life is miserable you know what will get
me away from this misery a luxury car a
luxury house uh any sort of
a watch right there's nothing wrong with
a watch but a buying a rolex will not
buy you more time in fact the opposite
is usually true if you can afford a
rolex i hear they make really great
diving watches and and and that's
wonderful and they're handmade and and
they're they can even be pieces of art
but if i buy that rolex because oh what
will ryan think about me then i'm not
even using it for its intended use
there's an auxiliary use for which i'm
using it i'm buying it so that maybe
ryan will think more highly of me here's
the paradox of that though ryan let's
say i do buy the rolex and you feel ten
percent better about me
[Laughter]
so what is that is that the type of
friendship that i want that that your
opinion of me increases or decreases
based on the consumer choices that i
make yeah
uh i would i would look 20 more highly
of you if you bought me a rolex
you watch ruined my christmas present
for him
uh here's my
short pithy answer the less we own the
less we're owned
you know more things mean
mo things mo
problems yes indeed but we all know the
popular saying the things we own end up
owning us and it's true so if you uh if
you want to live free you own less stuff
so i totally agree with the sentiment
here yeah because we get owned by our
things we're possessed by our
possessions and i want to talk to you a
lot more about that and sort of the
psychological emotional pain that
happens by over consumption but also
just by needing more stuff we'll talk
about that on the private podcast this
week we got so much more to talk about
emma what do you got for us in the
meantime here are some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
hey joshua and ryan
i do find a lot of value in the
minimalist and i wanted to share with
the listeners two apps that i use in
regards to clothing
number one is rent the runway it's an
app that you can rent formal dresses and
accessories
the cool thing about them is they send
you two dresses in two different sizes
to ensure that you will find the best
fit
and you can see photos of real people
wearing the dress to help you decide
what will work best for you it's perfect
for weddings or special occasions
so you don't have to buy a new item
and number two is thread up it's another
app that buys and sells gently used item
they send you a prepaid postage clean
out bag that you can fill up with your
unwanted items and you can get cash for
those items or
use the credit to purchase a new to you
item that you would find value in
it's a perfect way to get rid of items
that you no longer need and to purchase
a gently used new to you item
bonus you can return items that don't
fit or you don't like i personally try
to use it like a storage locker so you
can get rid of the things that you don't
want anymore buy some new to use things
and when those things aren't working
anymore or you're not finding value in
send them back as well
for cash or credit
the only negative thing about rent the
runway or thread up apps is
sorry joshua and ryan they don't have
men's items but thread up does sell
children's
gently used items so that's a great
option for a busy mom like me
thank you so much and keep up the good
work
hey guys
this message is from steve in palm beach
gardens florida i have a minimalism tip
i would like to share with my fellow
listeners
i'm in the process of becoming a
minimalist
i am constantly evaluating my
possessions and discerning my wants for
my needs
as well as questioning the value that
certain items bring to me personally
recently i was on the verge of selling
my beloved custom gibson es 335 guitar a
guitar that i truly enjoy and use often
i was convinced that this item needed to
go however i was still on the fence
i was ready to depart with one of my
most prized possessions but hesitant
the reason i wanted to get rid of this
item is because i have another electric
guitar
that i also use frequently i use both of
both of these guitars often and consider
to them to be what you all refer to as
tools as i began to clean up the guitar
and post an ad on craigslist
i began to look around at the ridiculous
amount of other items that still
occupied my home
in that moment i realized there were an
abundance of items that literally
brought me zero value and meant much
less to me than this guitar
i soon began to truly evaluate my
possessions
after taking a few weeks to think more
on this particular item i had i donated
and trashed so many other useless
objects in the process
if i had written out a list of every
item i owned and ranked them in order of
importance to me there would have been
hundreds below
this particular guitar
i learned a valuable lesson in this
process
i was so stuck on the idea of becoming a
minimalist and become and getting rid of
things that i forgot who i was in the
process
guitars are a big part of my life
so my fellow minimalists
don't get rid of the things that you
know bring you joy
get rid of all the no-brainers first
then if you reach a point where you
realize you still do not want that
particular item
maybe you will in fact still depart from
it but for me it was all the other crap
in my life that i needed to get rid of
first
not one of the few items
that i truly love all right y'all before
we get to our added value segment this
week we want you to know we got a bunch
more surprise questions this thursday on
patreon that's the minimalist private
podcast here's what jessica over on
patreon has to say what a fabulous hour
i've just spent with the minimalists i
have four pages of journaling
revelations in hand now i can't explain
how a sentence or a phrase spoken on
your private podcast sends me straight
toward deep clarity but today i wrote
and wrote and wrote about the precise
origin of my attachment to stuff for me
your private podcast has evolved from an
intrigue to a critical tool in the
development of a more deeply in tune
self
what a testimonial man you are so wise
and popular
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing
actually three things going on in the
life of the minimalist you probably
notice at the top of this episode we
have a new theme music not really our
theme song is still peter doran every
little thing you're going to hear that
at the end of this episode but we're
trying to get it drives me crazy ryan we
we listen i listen to podcasts you
listen to podcasts all the time when a
podcast starts with eight minutes of ads
and then there's a three minute theme
song and then an intro before the
interview and all of these things and
it's just like i just want to get right
into it yeah and so
we have this new intro by the way if you
haven't i know if you don't watch this
on youtube it's totally fine but if you
if you want to watch this episode just
go back and watch the beginning of it on
youtube so we have this new opening
sequence now it's seven seconds long and
it's uh two guys ike and brian shout out
to them over at ramsey solutions we
hired them outside of work to make this
new opening bumper for our youtube
videos and it's this this glowing orb
that turns into our logo that declutters
an entire room over the course of seven
seconds to this beautiful music which
was actually inspired by the music from
our first film so we have a quick seven
second or so intro at the beginning plus
ella will come in if there's been bad
words in an episode and she'll warn us
so we've got this brand new intro i just
wanted you to go back to our youtube
channel it's youtube.com the minimalist
you can check that out on this episode
or any future episode we're also in our
new studio i just finished part four of
the studio tour with jordan this week it
should be out by the time this episode
comes out
we have four parts of our studio tour
over at patreon and then i have a new
essay which you can read for free it's
called the burden i'm sorry the
boundaries of
discontent
i tweeted this line
and it was the boundaries of your
discontent
are marked by everything you tolerate
now you and i on a recent private
podcast episode ryan we talked about
sort of
low-grade misery
if you remember that yeah i want to do a
whole episode with you about low-grade
misery i think quite often it stems not
always but it often stems
from these little things that we
tolerate i'm gonna tolerate this little
slate this little aggression from this
person and before we know it everyone
around us is treating us poorly but it's
maybe it's because we have tolerated
that for so long yeah so there's an
essay we'll put a link to it in the show
notes it's called the boundaries of
discontent
and you can find it at the
minimalists.com
discontent as well for added value this
week ryan the ultimate luxury if we're
really talking about luxury
it's our health and if i could go back
to my 20 year old self i would have had
him take a blood test every year just to
it's funny because i would always take
my car every 3000 miles to get the oil
change and yeah they look at the fluids
and yeah i'm always out of windshield
wiper fluid
it's just an upcharge it's a luxury
windshield wiper fluid
and uh yeah turning signal fluid it's
always out for me yeah they charged me
hundreds of dollars every time you'd be
dumb not together man uh
you know i yeah i got my blood work done
um like four years ago and that it was
the first time that i had it done
in years and years and years and the
reason why i got it done was because i
had a family member pass away
unexpectedly
and young one too yeah young yeah in in
in their mid-20s wow and i'd
realize like man if this family member
would have just gotten some blood work
done
like they might have saved their life so
and you know they had no idea anything
was going on so it like sparked me to go
get a blood test and sure enough like i
had this uh
well type 2 diabetes runs in my family
so i'm like pre i have a predisposition
to type 2 diabetes and i was like on the
cusp of um yeah of getting it right and
with some like exercise and changing my
diet i was able to get
my hemoglobin a1c down
but yeah if it wasn't for that family
member passing away i would not have
gotten that blood test and who knows
where i'd be you know at this point
because once you get to a certain point
with type 2 diabetes like there's
there's really no going back
um so yeah i totally agree man blood
tests it's like getting it's more
important than getting the oil change in
your car that's right and yet very
rarely do we check what's going on
inside our body maybe i feel i feel okay
i feel fine fine thanks but like are we
really stopping and saying okay maybe
just once a year i'll get my blood take
i'll check my hormone levels especially
as we're getting older right um and so
bex and i did a podcast episode while
you were out of town this was a few
years ago with adam lamb from renew life
rx we talked about hormones women's
hormones in particular but also uh male
hormones and checking those hormone
levels because our society all of the
toxins that we breathe in or eat or or
all the toxins were steeped in toxicity
right and a lot of these are hormone
disruptors as well so understanding your
vitamin levels
your your hormones your iron all of
these these
important markers for health how much
inflammation do i have in my body most
of us have no idea so we don't even know
what to do
about it yeah and so i would certainly
every year i go and get my my blood
through adam you can go anywhere if you
want if you don't know where to go to
get your blood taken renewliferx.com
this is not an ad or a sponsorship i
have to pay him just like everyone else
does right but the thing he really
specializes in is also hormone
management as well
and so
you know being able to understand what
your blood work looks like and explain
that to you in a way so it's not just
coming back and saying well my c
reactive protein levels seem a little
bit high
well what does that mean exactly so
having someone walk you through it is
is really important yeah and so renew
life rx if you want to
get a blood test they have all the
details over there we'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well or like i
said you can go anywhere locally just
finding a doctor that will provide you
with the knowledge and insight and
wisdom so you know what to do with those
results
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like when does it
make sense to purchase certain luxury
items what's the real reason we purchase
items such as campers boats off-roading
vehicles cabins and vacation homes which
luxury brands have better business
practices as well as better quality and
durability why do we desire certain
items even though we know intellectually
that those things won't improve or
complete our lives plus a million more
questions about the emotional and
psychological burden of our material
possessions and if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast this week visit
patreon.com minimalists to subscribe and
get your personal link so that our
weekly private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app you also gain
immediate access to hundreds of hours of
private archives recordings of live
events monthly ask the minimalist
anything sessions and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers just like you subscribe today
at patreon.com
the minimalists you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists come to one
of our live podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple sunday email newsletter for
free and if you leave here today with
just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it